hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Walking Dead episode 12
video the first look inside the
Alexandria safe zone we also got to meet
a couple people that were right out of
the comics so I'll try to explain them
in the most non spoilery way possible so
just careful for spoilers as I start to
explain who these people are so here we
go
Deanna first she is a gender bent
version of Douglas Monroe from the
comics and aside from the gender
swapping she's pretty much the same as
she is in the comics
she's an Ohio representative she's a
politician so definitely don't trust her
in the comics Douglas did have a son
named Spencer but on the show Dan his
son's name is Aiden so Aiden might be a
little bit like Spencer in the comics at
least in tone like the characters are
both douchebags
but it seems like Aidan's character is
gonna be much more aggressive then we
have Jesse here also right out of the
comics she has a son named Ron on the
show she has two sons I don't want to
talk about her husband in the comics
because it's a little spoilery and they
kind of teed it up with Rick walking by
their porch but if your ears pricked up
whenever she and Rick were sharing
moments then you're on the right track
in general it seems like the show is
gonna be pretty faithful to the safe
zone of the comics with a few you know
minor changes not quite as many
characters if you have read the comics
and you want to talk about that stuff
just please use spoiler tags so here we
go top five moments number five welcome
to the safe zone this episode is one of
my favorites so far this season and for
very different reasons than I usually
get excited about episodes usually
Walking Dead is all about the gore all
about big zombie kills really awesome
effects sequences but this episode was
all about the group stepping into this
alternate dimension where they just they
couldn't fathom what was going on
because it looks so weird it's like they
all walk in and they're looking around
going what the hell is going on here
when I first graduated from college I
moved into a neighborhood kind of like
that and I had the exact same reaction
as like what is going on these people
look like aliens that being said I do
think that most of the members of the
group have their together
Carol totally isn't drinking the
kool-aid Rick knows what's up I mean he
puts that uniform on but that doesn't
mean that he's gonna stop being careful
I think the only one from start to
finish that just refuses to accept their
new reality is Daryl moving on to number
four say goodbye to Rick's beard may you
rest in peace this is so funny I mean
Andrew Lincoln had been walking around
in real life without a beard for a long
time so I think we all felt like yeah
eventually they're gonna trim it
it got so ridiculously long to its that
the minute Aaron showed up clean-shaven
you're like okay yep clearly he is from
a place where they own razors
so the beard is not long for this world
how many years though did it take off of
Rick's life when he cut that beard off I
mean he's not an old man but with that
beard he definitely looked like one it's
like he D aged by ten years the minute
he shaved and how convenient that
Alexandre Breckenridge's Jesse character
showed up right as he was finishing no
shirt on
clearly there's gonna be some
shenanigans going on there eventually
whenever they cast Alexander
Breckenridge they made a pretty big deal
about it she's one of the few characters
I mean there's a bunch of new characters
at the safe zone but she's one of the
few that they made a big deal about
publicizing so obviously they're gonna
focus a lot more on her in terms of all
these new people that just means that
she's gonna have a lot more scenes with
the group than the other new members of
the safe zone I think we're gonna be at
the safe zone for the rest of the season
so we will have time to meet all those
other characters but I just I feel like
they're gonna focus more on Jesse moving
on to number three Karl meets all the
children I like the way they have
parallels between the group members in
the way they experience the safe zone so
Karl is like the kid version of Darryl
completely cannot figure out how to
assimilate there is the Enid character
clearly he's gonna form a bond with her
I'm kind of interested to see what's
going on there she could wind up being
like a Clementine character from the
video game I don't think she is
Clementine or could go nowhere but I'm
more inclined to think that based on the
amount of time they spent setting her
character up teasing that something was
gonna happen between heard Carl that
they will pursue that definitely
something going on with rish own with
this new Jessie character and Rick and
now Karl has this new Enid character
just a lot of new friendships that are
gonna be born think about it this way
too a lot of times if the walking dead
ends up really liking an actor if their
performance ends up being way better
than they originally thought it would be
sometimes they'll turn them into cast
regulars in future seasons Robert
Kirkman has said not a number of times
though that this season will be much
more faithful to the comics so just
regardless look forward to lots of comic
book things moving on to number two The
Survivors clash with life at the safe
zone so everyone acts out just a little
bit in their own way Karl and Rick have
that weird moment where they get super
cranked up to kill walkers together I
guess that's like their version of catch
their version of playing catch in the
backyard and then you have Glenn Terra
and Noah clashing with Aiden's group
clearly Aiden off his rocker
they're all just having a hard time
assimilating I mean Darryl just like the
best visible example of that it's like
taking a wild dog and putting it in a
house like it'll just keep freaking out
till it adjusts or until you let it back
outside and finally my number one moment
Rick says that if it doesn't work out
don't worry we'll just take the place
the way use of the - such a great
delivery so casual like don't worry
we'll just we'll take it no big deal he
and Carol are so funny like it's like
they're wearing these weird clothes now
like Carol's dressed like a housewife
he's dressed like he used to as a
sheriff but underneath they're not
taking any I would say of all
the camera performances Carol's was my
favorite though everyone else seems so
earnest like Rick was honest he's like
closure gates don't trust anyone
Carol though was like oh I'm just a den
mother I just I loved working with other
people do you have any jobs in the
community do you have a Junior League
any organizations that I can help just
the way her face looked while she was
saying that seemed so earnest and so
funny I just I wanted to laugh so hard I
was like clearly she is just playing
this politician and that's another thing
too what is going on with Deanna if
she's a politician that means that she
lies for a living and if she's good
enough to win reelection that means
she's really good at manipulating people
I think just right now since she's just
met these people what she's doing is is
she senses that they're really tough so
she's keeping them close like she's
trying to make friends with them right
away like if you were to meet someone
who you sense was more powerful than you
you'd have a much easier time if you
befriended them rather than turn them
into an immediate enemy doesn't that
just feel like a politician thing to do
like if you saw an opponent that you
thought might be able to beat you in a
future election you try to turn them
into an ally rather than keep them from
becoming an enemy or potential threat in
the future but let me know though you
know of all the things that they teased
in the episode like potential future
conflicts with certain people especially
with Jesse's weirdo husband smoking
creepily on the porch what are you most
excited about one of the fun things I'm
really looking forward to is just seeing
Glenn beat the out of Aiden again
there's no way he's gonna let that go
Aidan is totally gonna challenge him
again at some point I already mentioned
most of the comic book Easter eggs I saw
like all that you know the people that
they pulled straight off the page but if
you saw any that I didn't mention just
listen in the comments below I think you
know one of the things that we need to
look out for is who took Rick's gun
what's going to happen with the other
men
verse of the community that we haven't
met yet and what is Aydin gonna do to
get revenge on Glenn based on what they
put in a teaser for the next episode I
think we're gonna learn a lot more about
Deanna next week so I think we'll find a
little bit more about what's going on
inside her head like what her grand plan
is for the survivors and remember the
producers and Robert Kirkman have said
that we're gonna meet a villain this
season that's just as bad as the
governor in the people at terminus don't
you just wonder if it's someone that we
met in this episode because I don't
think it's gonna be negan I think he
still weighs off so just a quick
reminder new round of the giveaway
starts now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
below
but I'll be posting next week's video
after the episode airs generally like
I'm actually really excited with the
direction the show is going right now I
mean it's weird because the tone of the
show is changing so much but I think
that's a good thing so while you guys
wait for my next Walking Dead video or
for the Q&A tomorrow you can click here
for last week's episode and you can
click here for my latest Game of Thrones
Season 5 video to learn all about dark
Sansa thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you